des formes des couleurs des odeurs mais
surtout beaucoup de savoir-faire c'est
ici depuis 2019 que Magalie coché Blin
professeur de formation a créé sa
savonnerie après une reconversion
professionnelle au programme de la
matinée fabrication du savon Saint-Louis
on est avec de l'huile d'amande douce un
savon tout type de peau et on est plus
l'huile d'Amand dou c'est connu pour
adoucir assouplir la peau il y a de
l'argile verte dedans c'est de l'ilite
surfine donc je travaille qu'avec ave
des argiles françaises qui va enlever en
fait les les corps gras donc voilà c'est
celui-là qu'on va
[Musique]
faire pour la fabrication tout se passe
en laboratoire une conception au degrés
et au gram
[Musique]
près je vais vérifier la température
s'il y a besoin de monter je vais monter
ça c'est l'huile d'olive on est sur
l'huile d'olive bio les recettes sont
déclarées au gram près on on est déclaré
à zéro ,01 g près ajouter à l'huile la
soude pour réaliser la saponification
vous avez vu il y a l'huile audessus et
en dessous ça commence à saponifier et
quand je
remue la saponification démarre
naturellement donc là ça veut dire que
l'huile est en train de se transformer
en savon à l'huile sont ajoutés des
éléments naturels ici de l'argile verte
là on est sur de l'élite argile
française sur fine c'est de l'argile
verte là je vais faire ce qu'on appelle
un one pot c'est un marbrage très très
classique la préparation est en ensite
versé dans des moules et devra refroidir
plusieurs heures pour ensuite pouvoir
être découpé à la
guitare il ne reste plus qu'à ajouter la
touche finale la signature de l'artisan
une fois le séchage terminé voici à quoi
ressemble le savon avec près de 4000
savons produits par an et disponible des
7 € l'artisane fait figure de référence
en 2020 elle reçoit par la ville de
poiss le prix de femme etmérite une
fierté au goût de revanche pour
l'ancienne professeur c'était pour mon
engagement écologique et puis la
création de bain d'étoil j'étais très
surprise puisque bain d'étoil avait 4
mois et 4 mois après recevoir ce type de
distinction voilà je me disais pourquoi
moi ça m'a donné un sacré l en fait ça
m'a permis de garder mes convictions et
puis d'aller plus loin
dans dans cette recherche de de
bien-être entre
la nature en septembre dernier c'est le
prix de l'excellence artisanale qui lui
est attribué faisant d'elle la seule
artisan d'excellence savonnière
siririère de France à ce
jour